passons aux sciences sociales.
En particulier, je veux que nous réfléchissions aux questions de savoir
où se trouve le potentiel de l'humanité
et où nous en sommes actuellement.
Quand on y réfléchit, il y a un grand fossé
entre où nous pensons pouvoir être et où nous sommes,
dans toutes sortes de domaines.
J'ai une question pour vous :
le mois dernier, combien d'entre vous ont mangé plus qu'ils ne devraient ?
En général. D'accord.
Le mois dernier, combien d'entre vous
ont fait moins de sport qu'ils ne devraient ?
Et pour combien d'entre vous lever deux fois la main -
a été l'activité la plus sportive de la journée ?
(Rires)
Combien d'entre vous ont déjà envoyé des messages en conduisant ?
Nous devenons honnêtes. Testons votre honnêteté.
Le mois dernier, combien de personnes
ne se sont pas toujours lavé les mains en sortant des toilettes ?
(Rires)
Un peu moins honnêtes.
Il est intéressant d'être prêt à admettre utiliser son téléphone au volant
mais ne pas se laver les mains, c'est difficile.
(Rires)
Nous pourrions continuer.
Le problème, le sujet, c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
que nous savons que nous pourrions faire --
nous pourrions être très, très différents, mais nous agissons différemment.
Quand nous pensons à comment combler cet écart,
la réponse habituelle est : « Dites-le aux gens. »
Dites aux gens qu'envoyer un message en conduisant est dangereux.
Saviez-vous que c'est dangereux ? Vous devriez arrêter.
Dites aux gens qu'une chose est dangereuse, ils arrêteront.
Les messages au volant sont un exemple.
Un autre triste exemple est qu'aux États-Unis,
nous dépensons entre sept et huit cents millions de dollars par an
pour de « l'alphabétisation financière ».
Qu'obtenons-nous en conséquence de cela ?
Une étude récente a considéré toutes les recherches jamais conduites
sur l'alphabétisation financière -- c'était une méta-analyse.
Ils ont découvert que quand vous dites aux gens,
que vous leur enseignez les finances,
ils apprennent et s'en souviennent.
Mais les gens mettent-ils en œuvre ?
Pas tellement.
L'amélioration est d'environ 3 ou 4%
immédiatement après le cours,
puis cela décroît.
Au final,
l'amélioration est d'environ 0,1% --
pas zéro, mais aussi proche de zéro qu'humainement possible.
(Rires)
C'est la mauvaise nouvelle :
donner des informations aux gens
n'est pas une bonne recette pour changer leur comportement.
Que faire ?
Les sciences sociales ont fait de grandes avancées
et l'information fondamentale est que si nous voulons changer le comportement,
nous devons changer l'environnement.
La façon de procéder n'est pas de changer les gens,
mais l'environnement.
Je veux présenter un modèle très candide pour percevoir cela :
voir le changement comportemental
comme nous voyons l'envoi d'une fusée dans l'espace.
Pour envoyer une fusée dans l'espace,
nous voulons faire deux choses.
Un : nous voulons réduire la friction.
Sur la fusée, nous voulons avoir aussi peu de friction que possible,
pour qu'elle soit aérodynamique.
Deux : nous voulons charger autant de carburant que possible,
lui donner le plus de motivation, d'énergie possible pour sa tâche.
Le changement comportemental, c'est la même chose.
Parlons d'abord de friction.
Dans l'étude de cas dont je vais vous parler,
il est question d'une pharmacie en ligne.
Imaginez que vous allez chez le médecin.
Vous avez une maladie chronique,
votre médecin vous prescrit un médicament,
vous vous inscrivez sur cette pharmacie en ligne
et vous recevez votre médicament par la poste tous les 90 jours.
Tous les 90 jours, médicament, médicament, médicament.
Cette pharmacie en ligne veut faire passer les gens
des médicaments de marque aux médicaments génériques.
Ils envoient une lettre aux gens et disent :
« S'il vous plaît, passez aux génériques.
Vous économiserez de l'argent, nous aussi et votre employeur aussi. »
Que font les gens ?
Rien.
La pharmacie essaye des choses et rien ne se passe.
Pendant un an, ils donnent aux gens une offre incroyable.
Ils envoient une lettre aux gens et disent :
« Si vous passez aux génériques, ce sera gratuit pendant un an. »
Gratuit pendant un an, génial !
A votre avis, quel pourcentage de gens ont changé ?
Moins de 10%.
A ce moment-là, la pharmacie vient à mon bureau.
Ils viennent se plaindre.
Pourquoi m'ont-ils choisi ?
J'ai écrit quelques publications sur « l'attrait du gratuit ».
Nous y avons montré que si vous réduisez un prix
de 10 centimes à un centime, par exemple, rien ne se passe.
Vous le faites passer d'un centime à zéro, les gens s'enthousiasment.
(Rires)
Ils ont dit : « Nous avons lu sur le "gratuit",
avons offert du "gratuit".
Ça n'a pas marché comme prévu.
Que se passe-t-il ? »
J'ai dit : « C'est peut-être une question de friction. »
Ils ont dit : « Comment ça ? »
J'ai dit : « Les gens ont de la marque.
S'ils ne font rien, ils finissent avec de la marque.
Pour passer aux génériques,
ils doivent les choisir plutôt que la marque,
mais ils doivent faire quelque chose :
ils doivent renvoyer la lettre. »
C'est ce que nous appelons une « conception faussée ».
Deux choses arrivent en même temps.
C'est la marque contre les génériques
mais c'est ne rien faire contre faire quelque chose.
J'ai dit : « Pourquoi ne pas inverser ?
Pourquoi ne pas envoyer de lettre disant : « Nous vous passons aux génériques.
Pas besoin d'agir.
Si vous voulez rester avec de la marque, renvoyez la lettre. »
(Rires)
Non ?
Qu'est-il arrivé ?
Des avocats, des avocats sont arrivés.
(Rires)
Il s'avère que c'est illégal.
Pour la phase de réflexion et de créativité,
faire des choses illégales et immorales, ce n'est pas grave,
tant que ce n'est que durant la phase de réflexion.
(Rires)
Mais c'était la pureté de cette idée,
car la conception initiale était
que la marque avait le bénéfice de l'absence d'action.
Dans ma conception illégale, immorale,
le générique avait le bénéfique de l'absence d'action.
Mais ils ont accepté de donner un choix obligatoire aux gens :
envoyer une lettre disant :
« Si vous ne renvoyez pas cette lettre,
nous serons obligés d'arrêter votre traitement.
Mais quand vous renvoyez cette lettre,
vous choisissez entre une marque à ce prix-là
et un générique à ce prix-là. »
Maintenant, les gens devaient agir.
Ils étaient sur un pied d'égalité.
L'un n'avait pas le bénéfice de l'absence d'action.
A votre avis, quel pourcentage a changé ?
La grande majorité a changé.
Qu'est-ce que ça nous dit ?
Les gens aiment-ils les génériques ou les marques ?
Nous détestons renvoyer des lettres.
(Rires)
C'est l'histoire de la friction : les petites choses comptent.
La friction, c'est prendre le comportement désiré
et dire : où avons-nous trop de friction,
tant et si bien que cela empêche les gens d'agir ?
Quand vous voyez que le comportement désiré
et le comportement facile ne sont pas alignés,
nous voulons essayer de les réaligner.
C'est la première partie : la friction.
Parlons de motivation.
Dans cette étude,
nous essayions de faire
que les gens très pauvres d'un bidonville appelé Kibera, au Kenya,
épargnent un peu d'argent pour les jours sans.
Si vous êtes très, très pauvre, vous n'avez pas d'argent de trop,
vous vivez au jour le jour
et, de temps en temps, une chose malheureuse arrive.
Quand une chose malheureuse arrive, vous n'avez nulle part où puiser,
vous empruntez.
Les gens de Kibera empruntent parfois avec des intérêts de 10% par semaine.
Bien sûr, il est ensuite très dur de s'en sortir.
Vous vivez au jour le jour, quelque chose arrive,
vous empruntez, les choses empirent encore et encore.
Nous voulions que les gens gardent un peu d'argent pour un jour sans.
Nous avons réfléchi à la motivation,
au carburant que nous devions ajouter à cela.
Nous avons essayé toutes sortes de choses.
A certains, nous envoyions un message par semaine disant :
« Essayez d'épargner 100 shillings » -- environ un dollar -- « cette semaine ».
A certains, nous envoyions un message comme s'il venait de leurs enfants.
Il disait : « Maman, papa, c'est le petit Joey » --
ou quel que soit le nom de l'enfant --
« Essayez d'épargner 100 shillings cette semaine
pour l'avenir de notre famille. »
Je suis juif, un peu de culpabilité, cela fonctionne toujours.
(Rires)
Certains recevaient 10%.
« Épargnez jusqu'à 100 shillings, nous vous donnerons 10%. »
Certains recevaient 20%.
Certains recevaient 10% et 20%
mais avec une aversion à la perte.
Qu'est-ce que l'aversion à la perte ?
C'est l'idée selon laquelle nous détestons perdre
plus que nous aimons gagner.
Pensez à quelqu'un qui a une condition de 10%
et qui y met 40 shillings.
Il met 40 shillings, nous lui en donnons quatre,
il nous remercie.
Il a renoncé à six shillings.
Il aurait pu avoir six shillings de plus pour 100,
mais il ne le voit pas.
Nous avons créé un pré-abondement.
Nous avons mis les 10 shillings au début de la semaine
et dit : « Ils vous attendent ! »
Puis si quelqu'un en met 40, nous disons : « Vous avez mis 40,
nous vous en laissons quatre, nous en reprenons six. »
Dans les deux cas, le montant donné avant ou après,
les gens reçoivent 10%.
Mais avec le pré-abondement,
ils voient l'argent non obtenu quitter leur compte.
Nous avons un SMS, un SMS des enfants, 10%, 20%,
l'abondement au début ou à la fin.
Nous avions une condition supplémentaire.
C'était une pièce d'environ cette taille
avec 24 nombres écrits dessus.
Nous leur avons demandé de mettre la pièce quelque part dans leur hutte
et toutes les semaines, avec un couteau, gratter le numéro la semaine --
semaine une, deux, trois, quatre --
y faire un moins s'ils n'avaient pas épargné
et de haut en bas s'ils avaient épargné.
Réfléchissez :
à votre avis, laquelle de ces méthodes a le mieux fonctionné ?
Un SMS, un SMS des enfants, 10%, 20%,
au début de la semaine, à la fin de la semaine et la pièce ?
Je vais vous dire ce que les gens pensent.
Nous avons réalisé ces études de prévision
aux États-Unis et au Kenya.
Les gens pensent que les 20% obtiendront de nombreuses actions,
moins pour les 10%,
les autres ne feront rien --
les enfants, la pièce, peu importe.
Les gens pensent que l'aversion à la perte aura un effet minime.
Que s'est-il vraiment passé ?
Envoyer un SMS de rappel une fois par semaine
aide beaucoup.
Bonne nouvelle !
Ce programme a duré six mois,
les gens oublient et leur rappeler, c'est bien.
10% à la fin de la semaine ont aidé un peu plus.
Les incitations financières marchent.
20% à la fin de la semaine, c'était comme 10%, pas de différence.
10% au début de la semaine
aident un peu plus.
L'aversion à la perte marche.
20% au début de la semaine,
comme 10% au début de la semaine, pas de différence.
Le SMS des enfants était aussi efficace
que 20% plus l'aversion à la perte,
ce qui est formidable, non ?
La motivation liée aux messages des enfants était formidable.
Une conclusion est que nous n'utilisons pas assez les enfants.
(Rires)
Bien sûr, je ne parle pas de travail des enfants.
Mais si vous pensez aux parents et à leurs enfants,
nous sommes les meilleurs possibles pour nos enfants,
nous pensons à l'avenir
et nous devrions réfléchir
à comment utiliser cette formidable source de motivation
pour inciter les parents à mieux se comporter.
La grande surprise de cette étude a été la pièce.
La pièce a doublé les économies par rapport à quoi que ce soit d'autre.
La question est : pourquoi ? Qu'avait cette pièce ?
Voici comment j'ai commencé à réfléchir à la pièce,
je reviendrai à cela plus tard.
Quand j'effectue des recherches sur l'achat de café,
je n'ai nulle part où aller, je reste dans mon bureau.
J'ai acheté assez de café, je connais le sujet.
Les détails me sont familiers.
Quand j'étudie l'un des endroits les plus pauvres au monde,
je dois y aller, visiter, voir ce qu'il s'y passe
et obtenir un aperçu du fonctionnement du système.
Ce jour-là,
j'étais à Soweto, en Afrique du Sud,
et j'étais à un endroit qui vendait des assurances obsèques.
Aux États-Unis, les gens dépensent des sommes folles pour les mariages.
En Afrique du Sud, ce sont les obsèques.
Les gens dépensent jusqu'à un ou deux ans de revenus pour les obsèques.
J'étais à cet endroit --
avant que vous ne jugiez les Sud-Africains comme étant irrationnels,
je voulais vous rappeler
qu'en dépensant beaucoup d'argent pour des obsèques et non un mariage,
au moins vous êtes certains que ça n'arrive qu'une fois.
(Rires)
Je suis dans ce lieu de vente d'assurances obsèques.
Un homme entre avec son fils -- son fils a environ 12 ans --
et il achète une assurance obsèques pour une semaine.
Cela couvrira 90% du coût de ses obsèques
uniquement s'il meurt dans les sept prochains jours.
Ce sont des gens très pauvres, ils achètent de courtes assurances,
de petits bouts de savon et autres.
Il obtient le certificat
et, de façon très cérémonieuse, il le donne à son fils.
Alors qu'il le donne à son fils, je me demande : pourquoi la cérémonie ?
Que fait ce père ?
Pensez au soutien de famille qui décide ce jour-là
de mettre de l'argent dans une assurance ou des économies.
Que va avoir la famille ce soir ?
Elle va avoir moins.
A ce niveau de pauvreté, il y aura moins de nourriture, de carburant, d'eau --
quelque chose de moins le soir.
Ce que ce père faisait et ce que notre pièce essayait de faire,
c'était de dire qu'il y avait moins à manger sur la table
mais il y avait une autre activité.
Il y a de nombreuses activités économiques bénéfiques et importantes,
comme les économies et l'assurance, qui sont invisibles.
La question est : comment les rendre visibles ?
Revenons-en à notre modèle pour les fusées.
Pour commencer, nous devons considérer le système
et voir où il y a des petites choses à corriger, avec de la friction,
où pouvons-nous éliminer de la friction ?
Ensuite, nous voulons réfléchir au système dans son ensemble
et dire : quelles autres motivations pouvons-nous introduire ?
C'est un exercice bien plus difficile
et nous ne savons pas ce qui va fonctionner le mieux.
Est-ce que ce sera l'argent, l'aversion à la perte
ou quelque chose qui est visible ?
Nous l'ignorons et devons essayer différentes choses.
Il faut réaliser que notre intuition nous induit parfois en erreur.
Nous ne savons pas nécessairement ce qui fonctionnera le mieux.
Si nous pensons à ce fossé
entre le possible et notre position,
c'est vraiment triste à voir et de penser à ce fossé.
La bonne nouvelle est que nous pouvons faire beaucoup de choses.
Certains changements sont simples, certains sont plus complexes.
Mais si nous nous attaquons directement au problème,
pas seulement en offrant plus d'informations aux gens
mais en essayant de changer la friction,
d'ajouter de la motivation,
nous pouvons...
Pouvons-nous combler ce fossé ? Non.
Mais pouvons-nous grandement nous améliorer ?
Oui, absolument.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)